I want to congratulate you had your
daughter in February this your first
baby yeah first thing first and last
shut it down
well I'm told she's she was big when she
was born right yes she was nine point
six pounds Wow that's what everybody
likes to talk about the weight of babies
cuz they're so boring otherwise yeah
like they're only interesting things
that's a big baby it's a huge baby yeah
yeah I went to the doctor the day before
she was born he's like this baby's
getting real big and she doesn't want to
come out and then he was like how do you
feel about a cesarean and I was like
great and and now I know a guy who's
really into my scar
[Applause]
yeah Tracy he'll be back there yeah now
you brought a picture from the hospital
you said this is your daughter your
first meal trying to serve her first
meal what happened there didn't really
yeah it's is she a big eater she's a
yeah she was I think in the womb she was
just bored and she was just like pulling
on the food too because there was
something to do and now she's like this
is what I whenever I best feed her
because I don't want you guys took call
child services and and I realized that
when I breastfeed her she looks at me
with like stress and anxiety and I
couldn't figure it out and then I was
like oh she thinks every time she goes
for the boob and looks up this face is
looking down at her just waiting so I
think she thinks that I want the boob -
Oh every time that she goes to eat
there's me just being like hey when do I
get the booth let me just have this boob
let me eat along every time I'm eatin
here now okay you film this is
impressive I don't even send me how you
did this but you filmed right up until
the day before you gave birth or a baby
that is in that's you has been very
uncomfortable yeah well I was acting for
two and she didn't get paid but she had
a lot of creative control over the
character mainly that Carol would just
limp everywhere she was just like
grinding into my hip yeah so I can't
really move and then they got me a
wheelchair and that was pretty awesome
they would wheel you around in between
takes yeah well it had to be it and then
for blocking they'd be like so Carol
walks over and grabs the gun and I'm
like maybe Carol sitting by the gun like
if someone hands her the guy she's lying
down eating chocolates yeah and it was
and because it was right up until I went
into labor cuz forte is like Oh Garin
boron that I was like okay they got a
four take care you know you're just
gonna you know he doesn't care what he
just wants to get his show shot you know
yeah his baby as the show yeah and so
the so they got a double who looks like
me and so just in case you went into
labor and they said yeah and there was a
couple days that I just couldn't do it
and you'll see in the final episode
Carol wears a sleep apnea mask and and
sunglasses and sometimes it's me and
sometimes it's my double Daniella and
sometimes I'm under the mats and
sometimes she's under the baths and I
just think it'd be a real fun game for
people at home well then we have a
picture of you with Daniella and yeah
you chew a there's a real similarity
there yeah you guys become friends know
what I got a little bitty but but she's
great um casting directors you should
cast her she's wonderful she's got my
mannerisms down which is a little
nerve-racking yeah
you